when we did our video interview series
with you in 2013 I think we asked you
some of the best films to watch to learn
the craft of filmmaking right now that
serialized you know TV shows are like
the big sort of that's taken their new
place sort of in in media consumption
what do you think some of the best
serialized content is hmm you try the
best like dramatic the best dramatic
television yeah to learn the the craft
of storytelling oh well that's
interesting
I you know I I'm a bit of uh I'm a bit
of a movie snob I guess in that I've
always looked to films feature films as
as my nourishment and I you know I think
after watching television the 70s as a
kid you know you know whether they were
sitcoms like mash or on the family or
good time yeah or any of those things
you know I didn't watch it I haven't
really studied watched a lot of serial
television although I do watch a lot of
oddly enough I end up watching more
British dramatic television than
American television and I think that's
because I tend to think that the British
actors and and even the British
directors I think are actually stronger
in television and I just started to find
that a few years ago as I started to
watch and there was just you know now a
show like a show like Sherlock you know
which made Benedict Cumberbatch a star I
started to watch that again and I was
you know I look at that show in the same
way I look at any any any film which is
just like how is it shot how is it
blocked what are the performances like
you know is it working and Sherlock is a
show that I you know that I watched and
I'm like yeah this is just a really well
directed piece of television and I went
and I think that's probably to me that's
like the best kind of judge when you
watch a television show in the same way
that you watch a film where you get
caught up and it's funny cuz like I just
wanted to see I said I want to see the
last x-men movie just to get out of the
summer heat and I can't remember there
wasn't and Bryan Singer's obviously you
know and
Norma slike pible director but there
wasn't anything new or interesting or
resonant and that it didn't didn't I
didn't get caught up in that in the same
way I got caught up in an episode of
Sherlock from five years ago or whenever
the show I was just watching that on
Netflix and I was like oh yeah you know
this is really good so I think it you
know I also I think there's movement
between definitely movement of directors
and writers from from television into
film and back again there's a lot of
that now when there wasn't so much for
foreign you could say well he's a
television director he's a television
writer and he said but unfortunately I'm
probably the last person to give advice
on what television to watch I think some
of the ones that people certainly
obviously Breaking Bad is a show that
people are enormous ly supportive of and
they admire the shooting in that and
what I've seen of that show it's
obviously enormous ly thoughtful and
creative directing going on in that show
other people are enormous fans of Mad
Men and there's a million shows I mean I
think back I'm going back on HBO shows
like The Sopranos thinking that show was
always you know a well-directed but I
again I gauge that on whether as a
viewer and again filmmakers are much
more critical if I get caught up in the
thing in the story and the performances
and I just get caught up in the story
then it doesn't matter that it's working
that it's a good piece of filmmaking
regardless of whether it's it's a TV
show or whether it's a movie
you